madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition les élections en allemagne le
chancelier helmut kohl et battu 35 5%
des voix contre 41 % à son adversaire
gerhard schröder
le leader des sociaux démocrates sera le
prochain chancelier de l'allemagne un
tournant historique c'est la fin de
l'ère kohl analyses commentaires de nos
envoyés spéciaux
avec comme invités notamment daniel cohn
bendit à toulon 2e tour des législatives
partielles le taux de participation
avoisine les 50% soit six points de plus
que la semaine dernière les premiers
résultats dans ce journal
sur les champs elysées le défilé du
siècle pour les 100 ans du salon
automobile des véhicules datant de 1898
au prototype de jonnhy l'actualité de ce
dimanche dominé par les élections en
allemagne d'après les premières
estimations le chancelier kohl est battu
l'homme à la tête du pays depuis 16 ans
obtiendrait 35 5% des voix contre 41 % à
son adversaire
gerhardt schröder c'est un tournant
historique le chancelier kohl ne
gouvernera donc pas l'allemagne de l'an
2000 c'est la fin de l'ère kohl
le leader du parti social démocrate
comme le prévoyaient les derniers
sondages l'emportent avec une légère
avance
les électeurs dont on disait qu'un sur
cinq étaient encore indécis ce matin
auront finalement tranché et nous
retrouvons tout de suite olivier lerner
vous êtes en direct à bonn au siège du
parti social-démocrate de gerard
schröder
je ne sais pas si l'état major du parti
est déjà sur place mais on peut supposer
qu'il règne un climat plutôt euphorique
tout le monde est déjà sur place depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant et je peux
vous dire qu'il ya autour de nous plus
de 2000 personnes des journalistes du
monde entier bien sûr mais aussi des
beaunois rassemblés ici et tout à
l'heure gerhard schröder en s'adressant
à nous nous a livré un petit message
avant de se mettre au travail
le nouveau chancelier veut faire la fête
alors nous verrons bien dans la soirée
ce que cela donnera en attendant ce que
l'on peut dire ce soir c'est que cette
victoire est vraiment historique c'est
une grande victoire pour la gauche un
gouvernement rouge vert c'est du jamais
vu en allemagne
alors cette coalition cette cohabitation
elle existe bien
dans le pays dans certaines régions ce
n'est pas toujours facile daniel cohn
bendit pourra certainement vous en dire
plus tout à l'heure c'est la première
fois aussi qu'un chancelier est renversé
par le peuple les chanceliers reverser
l'ont été dans le passé par des ruptures
d'alliance au parlement mais jamais par
la voie des urnes
ce soir c'est une victoire pour trois
parties la gauche qui a infligé un
véritable camouflet à helmut kohl qui
doit prendre dès à présent sa retraite
politique c'est une victoire aussi pour
les verts qui vont gouverner avec sans
doute yoshka fischer qui va devenir
ministre des affaires étrangères et puis
une victoire également à ses éclatantes
pour le pds les ex communistes s'ils se
maintiennent pour l'instant avec les
chiffres que nous avons avec plus de 5%
des voix et bien les ex communistes vont
peser dans la vie politique allemande à
partir du mois prochain
merci olivier nous en parlerons bien sûr
avec tous nos invités philippe rochot
vous aide directe maintenant du siège
des chrétiens-démocrates j'imagine que
les résultats de ces élections était
accueilli plutôt fraîchement c'est une
surprise en tout cas une immense
déception pour les militants oui c'est
vrai c'est une grande déception vous
savez ici les chrétiens démocrates
avaient organisé une fête ou de 5000
personnes devaient venir il ya ici 500
journalistes qui attendaient une
nouvelle victoire du chancelier kohl ça
ne s'est pas fait les gens sont déçus
pour l'instant les ministres du
gouvernement qu ils sont en train de le
saluer de le consoler quelque peu aussi
on a vu ici passé wolfgang schauble son
son dauphin en quelque sorte on a vu
paul que rouas le ministre de la défense
et puis à l'heure actuelle on sait que
cole va se retirer il va prendre sa
retraite en quelque sorte mais il va
quand même réunir l'état major du parti
politique des chrétiens démocrates pour
expliquer pour tirer les leçons de cet
échec en tout cas ce soir vous l'avez
dit c'est la déception et cette fête qui
devait réunir quelques 5000 personnes
est en train de se terminer
tout le monde rentre chez soi le coeur
gros pour les chrétiens-démocrates et le
chancelier helmut kohl à la télévision
il ya quelques instants tout juste a
reconnu sa défaite et annoncé sa
démission à la tête de la cd où nous
l'écoutons j'assume la responsabilité de
la défaite j'ai conduit cette campagne
pour notre parti vous tous
vous m'avez soutenu ce dont je vous
remercie mais en tant que chef de cette
campagne
j'assume la responsabilité de la défaite
sans aucune restriction
cette défaite est évident c'est vous
dire
helmut kohl avait l'habitude de dire les
autres gagnent les sondages moi je gagne
les élections le chancelier qui
hésitaient à l'instant se représenter
aura donc perdu sur la dernière ligne
droite
portrait de cet homme qui a modelé
pendant plus de 16 ans l'allemagne son
image restera celle de la réunification
et de l'euro philippe rochot les dix
filles ont le pouvoir de donner la force
à neutral surtout quand il s'agit de
persuader les allemands de l'est des
bienfaits de sa politique
c'est pourtant grâce à lui que la
réunification allemande a pu se faire au
même endroit à berlin il y a neuf ans il
s'était adressé à ces allemands de l'est
qui sortait à peine de 40 ans de
communisme
helmut kohl
né en 1930 n'avait pas 15 ans à la fin
de la guerre mais sa foi dans la
religion catholique et dans la paix en
europe en ont fait très tôt un
admirateur de konrad adenauer le premier
chancelier de l'allemagne fédérale
ce fils d'un petit fonctionnaire s'est
imposé rapidement dans sa région natale
de rhénanie palatinat
à 43 ans il prend ainsi la tête du parti
chrétien-démocrate lattes cd ou sur une
motion de défiance votée par la droite
contre 8,8 le social démocrate va le
propulser à la chancellerie à 52 ans
et c'est lui qui sera au rendez vous de
l'histoire pour les retrouvailles entre
les deux allemagnes il va mener tambour
battant son pays sur la voie de la
réunification le deutschmark s'impose à
tous les allemands les forces alliées à
les forces soviétiques se retire
d'allemagne cette souveraineté retrouvée
lui vaut d'être à nouveau à la
chancellerie pour un troisième mandat
son amitié avec françois mitterrand
renforce la relation franco-allemande la
réunification va coûter aux allemands
des milliards de marks
il faut rebâtir un pays dominé par 40
ans de communisme
cole a le soutien des européens et
malgré les sacrifices imposés les
allemands le désigne à nouveau pour un
quatrième mandat
les socialistes n'ont jamais trouvé de
dirigeants capables de renverser helmut
kohl dont la solidité l'assurance et la
fermeté rassure les allemands au sein de
son parti les chrétiens démocrates
aucun homme capable comme lui de gagner
la confiance des électeurs ne sait
vraiment détaché
helmut kohl a battu le record de
longévité de son maître
konrad adenauer qui a passé 14 ans à la
chancellerie
les allemands lui reconnaissent le
mérite d'avoir fait le bon choix
quand le mur de berlin est tombé et
d'avoir su convaincre pour imposer la
monnaie unique
helmut kohl va de toute façon rester
dans l'histoire comme une force de la
nature qui a su en créer un peu plus
l'allemagne dans l'union européenne
cette photo instantanée maintenant des
premières réactions sur le terrain des
militants qui se trouve depuis la fin de
l'après midi au siège du cd ou philippe
rochot les visages étaient crispés tout
à l'heure à l'annoncé des premiers
résultats qui confirment est en fait
très sondage met en action tian quelque
peu l'écart entre les sociaux-démocrates
et les chrétiens démocrates
dès 18h ces gens s'est invité ses
militants ont senti que le vent de
l'histoire avait tourné pour helmut kohl
ils savent à présent que leurs
chancelier va se retirer
soulevez soulever ça fait mal on a
toujours pensé que le spd ne
parviendrait pas à réaliser le score qui
était prévu dans les sondages mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
je ne pensais pas non plus que l'écart
entre les deux parties serait aussi
grand mais une différence de quelques 5
% ça fait quand même beaucoup
les partisans de la de céder ou n'ont
guère eu le temps de se consoler avant
l'arrivée du chancelier kohl venu tirer
sa révérence
une heure seulement après la fermeture
des bureaux de vote
je vous propose maintenant de suivre le
parcours du favori de ces élections qui
s'est présenté tout au long de la
campagne comme le manager de l'allemagne
gerhard schröder qui sera donc le
prochain chancelier allemand
cet homme âgé de 54 ans est issu d'un
milieu très modeste il a fait des études
d'avocat avant de se lancer dans la
politique
très tôt il a adhéré au parti social
démocrate un leader populaire sachant
manier la presse et les médias
portrait olivier lerner il va devoir
abandonner son bureau de ministre
président à hanovre en basse saxe
la région c'est fini maintenant c'est
l'allemagne c'est l'europe qui l'attend
je suis pour le rock rassembleur 109
je vais lutter pour moderniser les
rouages du système européen et j'ai deux
priorités pour ça le social et
l'empereur longue
élu pour quatre ans il va diriger la
république depuis berlin
on attend de lui qu'il s'impose vite
dans son nouveau costume et dans ses
nouveaux murs les dix marques vous aimez
le pouvoir bara mann non je ne suis pas
particulièrement attiré par le clone
wars
mais on a besoin de moyens pour faire
passer ses idées et les imposer
pour autant le pouvoir ne me fait pas
peur on l'obtient ici de façon
démocratique pour une période bien
définie pouvoir les hommes politiques ne
peuvent pas s'en passer c'est comme ça
gerhard schröder n'a pas fini d'entendre
l'hymne allemand qu'il aime tant ce
qu'il apprécie un peu moins ce sont les
cérémonies officielles très fréquentes
dans ce pays fini les flâneries en kit
liberté la bière le cigare qu'il s'y met
déjà en cachette pour ne pas trop porter
ses camarades de gauche
les sociaux-démocrates ont porté au
pouvoir un homme qui a longtemps
troubler les esprits au sein du parti
ancien marxiste ses idées
révolutionnaires sur l'économie nous
valut d'être mise à l'écart à plusieurs
reprises il a longtemps marché en
solitaire puis il a pris le sillage de
billy branch et d'helmut schmidt une
carrière en dents de scie une réputation
d' homme instable
cela ne l'a pas empêché de décrocher le
titre le plus prestigieux en allemagne
il est chancelier et voici est
précisément la première déclarations de
gerhard schröder qui s'exprimait il ya
quelques instants des quotas je voudrais
mesdames et messieurs témoigneront cet
instant tout mon respect à helmut kohl
il a été comme il fallait s'y attendre
un adversaire coriace mais les électeurs
ont décidé du futur gouvernement de
notre pays
notre devoir sera de moderniser
l'allemagne en profondeur et de
rattraper le retard dans la mise en
oeuvre des réformes
par ce vote les électrices et les
électeurs allemands ont ouvert la porte
un changement de génération voyons
maintenant les estimations des petites
formations les verts obtiendraient 6,6
pour cent
les libéraux 6,5 les ex communistes avec
5,2 pour cent pourrait faire donc une
entrée remarquée au parlement
l'extrême droite quand elle obtient 3 5%
c'est deux fois plus qu'il ya quatre ans
mais insuffisant pour être représenté au
parlement et nous retrouvons en direct
de frankfort daniel cohn bendit bonsoir
je voudrais d'abord m'adresser non pas
aux militants mais à celui qui connaît
parfaitement l'allemagne on disait les
électeurs frileux hésitant quelle
lecture donnée vous de ces résultats la
lassitude ou la volonté de changer oui
je crois que l'allemagne voulait changer
c'est la première fois effectivement
qu'en allemagne chancelier était battu
haute pendant les élections grâce à des
élections et ça vous dire que
l'allemagne ne voulait plus de col
l'allemagne a décidé alors après vingt
ans d'opposition le spd arrive au
pouvoir est ce que finalement c'est le
choix s'est davantage fait sur les
hommes et sur la personnalité de
schröder que sur les programmes labour
16 ans mais après le choix s'est fait
sur les hommes et donc un peu le
programme les hommes représentent un
certain programme
les allemands voulaient veulent une
allemagne plus sociale et plus
écologique et maintenant il faut que
cette majorité arrive à se faire
politiquement ça ça se décidera dans les
prochains jours alors non on en parle
tout de suite dans un instant vécu
que pensez vous de cette phrase qu'on a
entendu pendant la campagne cool me
tombe des mains et schroeder me
désespère au fond les allemands voter
sans trop savoir pourquoi est ce que
c'est votre avis je crois que je crois
que c'est pas vrai ça c'est un jeu des
médias les allemands comme tout
électorale à ils ont eu peur d'un
changement un certain moment parce que
changer c'est prendre un ris garder côté
paris changé c'est de prendre un risque
et au dernier moment
d'une manière beaucoup plus net qu'on ne
le croyait se sont décidés surtout si
ces allemands mais également du centre
se sont portés d'une manière quand même
plus importante que ne le disaient les
sondages du côté de schröder donc en
fait ils ont voulu ce changement les
allemands veulent le changement
non pas d'une manière frileuse vaut
mieux un électorat prudent sceptiques
que de l' enthousiasme qui en fait sera
après bafoués au bout de quelques jours
donc je crois que la situation est très
bonne pour le changement
alors encore une question avant de
m'adresser vraiment aux militants et on
sent le bon sens poindre du j'adore dans
vos réponses
peut-on dire que la chute de cole s'est
beaucoup joué à l'est dans l'ex rda qui
a d'une certification sanctionner le
chancelier oui la chose de cool s'est
joué à l'est cole a dit tout va bien
elle est alors que les gens disent tout
va mal n'est ce donc là il a perdu il
n'a pas gagné à l'ouest les gens n'ont
pas dit d'accord ça va mal à l'aise mais
ça va bien l'ouest ce qui n'est pas le
cas donc ça va mal à l'ouest un peu
moins beaucoup moins calès mais ça va
pas bien du tout et donc ils sont dit
les chrétiens-démocrates colis non plus
l'imagination nécessaire pour faire face
à la crise et c'est ça qui a permis à
schneider de gagner alors daniel cohn
bendit jean vient ouvert maintenant
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas fait campagne
d'après les premières déclarations le
leader du parti social démocrate refuse
de parler de coalition en tout cas pour
l'instant
les verts ont assuré leur maintien au
parlement en quoi seront ils des
partenaires nécessaires du prochain
gouvernement
écoutez en allemagne vous avez la
proportionnelle les sociaux démocrates
n'ont pas la majorité absolue donc il
faut qu'il fasse une coalition ils ont
deux possibilités ou avec les verts sans
soutien et là ça dépend mathématiquement
pour l'instant il ya une majorité de
quatre sièges plus des mandats directs
qu'on ne connaît pas moi j'aime à mon
estimation sera une dizaine de sièges
d'avancé pour les sociaux démocrates et
les verts
à partir de là évidemment il aurait la
possibilité de faire une coalition avec
les chrétiens-démocrates mais moi je
vais vous dire pourquoi d'après moi ça
c'est une analyse il n'y aura pas de
majorité avec les chrétiens démocrates
parce que les chrétiens démocrates ne
voudront pas il serait complètement fou
ils ont perdu les élections donc ils
vont dire aux sociaux-démocrates et
ouvert à vous
de gouverner pour essayer de retourner
la barre dans quatre ans 6 entre au
gouvernement les chrétiens démocrates
ça sera et qui font du bon travail
treize victoires de schröder donc ils ne
pourront pas gagner dans quatre ans donc
pour - il est presque sûr que s'il ya
une majorité entre sociaux démocrates et
verts que les chrétiens-démocrates
refusons d'aller au gouvernement avec
schneider pour des raisons politiques
évidentes il faut qu'il y ait une forte
un gouvernement et une forte opposition
et donc ils vont jouer la carte du
revenu de renouvellement dans
l'opposition ça évidemment l'avenir nous
le dira une dernière question daniel
cohn bendit pour la france l' axe paris
bonn qui d'ailleurs va devenir l' axe
paris berlin restera privilégié où la
france va devenir un partenaire parmi
d'autres non tout le monde sait que la
construction européenne quelque chose de
fondamental pour l'allemagne se joue
autour de l' axe paris berlin paris
bonne et il est évident que aujourd'hui
l'acce jospin schroeder ira très bien et
même lac ce temps qui la cohabitation
schröder chirac parce que et schneider
et chirac sont des bêtes politiques et
le futur gouvernement mme assad
le futur ministre des affaires
étrangères pardon allemand qui sera
peut-être vraisemblablement un vert
joschka fischer vous allez voir il s'en
trouvera non seulement très bien avec
védrine et jospin mais même peut-être
avec chirac parce que celui aussi c'est
une bête politique et quand on gouverne
on gouverne pas pour un parti mais on
gouverne pour un pays
merci daniel cohn bendit d'avoir répondu
à nos questions messages de
félicitations de jacques chirac à gerard
schröder puisque vous parlez de jacques
chirac et le parti socialiste salue avec
joie la victoire du spd et de gerhard
schröder
on l'a dit tout au long de la campagne
les votes de la population de l'ex rda
seront décisifs
l'ex allemagne de l'est touchés de plein
fouet par le chômage
l'exemple à magdebourg huan pour signer
christian hutin sont allés à la
rencontre des électeurs bureau de vote
du quartier holden stadt ce matin une
cité considéré comme difficile dans une
ville de l'est
ravagée par le chômage et où l'extrême
droite a réalisé 13 % aux dernières
élections
la tendance générale ce matin
était au vote pour le spd de gerhard
schröder il est jeune et dynamique
il a de bonnes idées et je crois qu'il a
plus d'énergie pour imposer ses idées
cole est usée après 16 ans de pouvoir là
c'est dennis était bien pendant la
réunification nouveau mart
mais maintenant ils ont relâché leur
effort surtout dans le domaine social a
toujours dit qu'il a créé de nouveaux
emplois mais les chiffres sont contre
lui
pourtant aux lgv est et a changé comme
partout en ex-allemagne de l'est les
façades sont en cours de réhabilitation
grâce à l'argent public investi ici et
le chômage continue de pousser certains
électeurs vers les extrêmes jamais
chasseurs en fait je extrême droite car
il ya beaucoup car joueurs partis à
l'étranger
il faut utiliser la priorité pour
l'allemagne si l'on reste que le clan
donnez moi
selon les premiers résultats l'extrême
droite réussit au niveau national a
doublé son score de 94 autant de déçus
de la politique est parfois de la
réunification que le nouveau chancelier
devra savoir convaincre lourde tâche
pour laquelle les allemands semblent
avoir choisi gerhard schröder social
démocrate en france à toulon 2e tour
aujourd'hui des élections législatives
partielles le taux de participation est
en hausse par rapport à la saison
dernière à 19 heures il atteignait près
de 50 pour cent soit six points de plus
que la semaine précédente
michaël darmon vous êtes en direct de
toulon c'est ont maintenant qui a
remporté de sandrine le chevalier ou de
dettes casanova cette élection
mais côté batterie se sont dans le jour
de vous dire que c'est odette qu'est la
nova la candidate de la gauche plurielle
qui est élu dans cette élection
législative partielle à toulon selon les
résultats partiels que nous possédons
transmis par la préfecture du var et sur
8800 bulletins dépouillés
audet casanova obtient donc 52 53 20 %
des voix tandis que sandrine le
chevalier du front national ne recueille
que 4 46,80 % des suffrages
oui et donc la participation a été plus
importante un transfert de votants
également plus importants et
tout indique donc sandrine chevalier et
le front national pour la deuxième fois
consécutive son va tout et sur tout le
monde merci michael et puis ce résultat
aussi deux législatives partielles dans
les bouches du rhône qui nous parvient à
l'instant c'est le communiste alain
belviso qui a donc remporté cette
élection avec 51% virgule 20 des voix
devant le candidat de la droite qui est
donc battu élections toujours avec
aujourd'hui en france le renouvellement
du tiers des sénateurs à la chambre
haute ce sont les grands électeurs qui
ont désigné les sénateurs pas de
surprise à attendre pour le
renouvellement de cette institution
devinez par une majorité écrasante de
droite en direct du sénat jean baptiste
près dali quels sont les premiers
résultats
oui bien vous l'avez dit la majorité
sénatoriale ce soir est à droite
seule surprise à signaler l'élection en
haute-corse du divers droite paul natali
par ailleurs mis en examen précédemment
dans une affaire de marchés publics
alors globalement à l'heure qu'il est on
a une petite poussée du rpr et des
libéraux quelques sièges en moins pour
les centristes et une progression moins
forte que prévu des socialistes alors
rené monory le président du sénat et
daniel vaillant le ministre des
relations avec le parlement
on réagit tout à l'heure je vous propose
d'écouter leurs commentaires sur cette
élection
pour la majorité du sénat et ont sabré
on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs maintenant que
lorsqu'on est uni va prendre un très bon
résultat puisque les banques et sociales
permettront pas peut-être d'un ou deux
aujourd'hui ça si on y avait peu de
surprise à attendre dans la mesure où
surtout pas les électeurs qui se sont
prononcés aujourd'hui mais des grands
électeurs décidés par des élus s'était
fondée notamment sur les dernières
élections municipales sur les élections
régionales et cantonales
c'est donc une grande stabilité même si
les changements à l'intérieur même des
départements alors prochaine étape ici
jeudi prochain l'élection du président
du sénat
deux candidats sont en lice pour le
moment à droite rené monory le président
centriste sortant et christian poncelet
sénateur rpr qui n'a pas pour l'instant
l'investiture de son beau merci jean
baptiste à thionville la confusion dans
l' enquête du meurtre du petit adrien
après les aveux d'un premier suspect qui
s'est rétractée hier puis
l'interpellation d'un deuxième homme qui
nie en bloc tous d'eux écroué dans la
soirée d'hier
un difficile maintenant de faire la part
des choses jérôme soûlard patrice
machefert quatre mois dans qu'être bien
difficile et une affaire d'assassinât
d'enfants qui s'accélère enfin avec les
aveux d'un suspect alex de 36 ans mise
en examen cette nuit pour homicide
volontaire devant juge d'instruction il
a réitéré ses aveux en expliquant qu'il
avait effectivement de façon
involontaire tuer ce gamin puisqu'il lui
avait donné un coup au visage parce
qu'il criait alors qu'il essayait
d'avoir des relations viré de caractère
homosexuel mais on le touche ont un peu
désaveu terriblement détaillé mais que
le suspect va immédiatement retiré quant
au présumé complice nicolas
il nie tout en bloc après cinq heures
d'audition les avocats sont un peu
sceptiques
bah on a surtout l'impression d'être
complètement perdu quoi plus à la drogue
at war et moins pour prendre choses et
je dirais dean raconte un petit peu le
tout au tout et son contraire et mon
client reste sur sa version à savoir
qu'il a rien à voir dans ce dossier quoi
alex dean c'est bien le personnage
central de cette confusion
un homme secret qui vivait seule dans
cette chambre louée salariés depuis
quatre mois ce divorce est homosexuel
semblaient apprécier particulièrement la
compagnie des enfants l'adoraient
enfants il va mal je vois mal faire du
mal à nos frais maintenant
si c'est vraiment ouais je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé et je rentrais de
plaisanter joue avec les enfants très
sympathique d'ailleurs il côtoyait pas
mal de vendée puis c'est vrai col voyant
jamais on n'aurait pas ces fabricants
les enquêteurs doivent maintenant
s'attacher à vérifier sérieusement les
aveux du suspect difficile car ici les
mensonges et les rumeurs les plus folles
courte aujourd'hui dans toute la ville
le mystère de la mort du petit adrien
reste encore à ce jour une énigme en
belgique après la démission du ministre
de l'intérieur qui a confirmé hier soir
sa décision c'est luc vanden borre qui a
été nommé immédiatement il est surtout
connu dans la région flamande dont il
est l'actuel ministre de l'enseignement
au chapitre médical cette campagne
d'information sur l'asthme est une
maladie qui touche près de 3 millions de
personnes en france
un chiffre en constante augmentation la
rentrée scolaire est une période propice
pour sensibiliser les parents au
dépistage française valayden gicquel
ludivine 1 6 ans et est asthmatique
depuis trois ans sa maman aussi à de
l'asthme depuis sa petite enfance
mais elle n'a pas pensé que sa fille
pourrait être malade à son tour
jusqu'au jour où les symptômes ont été
plus importants elle ronfler déjà et
adorent mais la bouche ouverte et le
matin c'était des éternuements sans
arrêt et même la nuit elle n'arrêtait
pas pousser pousser tout ça va ludivine
a consulté un médecin et subit des tests
elle souffre en fait d'un asthme
d'origine allergique son pire ennemi
c'est la poussière ou plus précisément
les acariens des insectes microscopiques
qui vivent un peu partout dans la maison
et objet de faire la poussière tous les
jours l'aspirateur c'est tous les jours
quand je fais ça change j'adorais elle
est déjà mais dans la chambre je la fait
sortir parce qu'avec la poussière chez
professionnels
chaque jour ludivine prend des
médicaments pour empêcher la maladie
d'évoluer mais les mesures d'hygiène
font partie de son traitement
80% des enfants asthmatiques sont
sensibilisés aux acariens c'est vraiment
à l'allergène majeur qu'on va devoir
ciblé par tous les moyens non traiter
l'asthme peut s'aggraver et empêcher les
poumons de l'enfant de se développer
normalement aujourd'hui l'asthme est
mieux connue mais la maladie n'est pas
toujours des pistes est super fort c'est
la maladie chronique la plus fréquente
en pédiatrie
on peut calculer qu'il n'est en france
un futur asthmatiques toutes les dix
minutes ce qui vous indiquent l'étendue
du problème
une enfant qui tousse les nuits ce n'est
peut-être rien mais c'est peut-être de
là par cette campagne nationale les
associations espèrent favoriser le
dépistage de la maladie
l'asmo pouces on le voit ni on se porte
ça les pyrénées atlantiques toujours
aucune trace de quatre spéléologue
disparu depuis plus de 48 heures
une équipe de secours est remontée du
gouffre de la pierre saint-martin sans
avoir trouvé de trace de ses hommes
en tout une vingtaine de gendarmes et de
spéléologues sont mobilisés la louisiane
menacée par le cyclone georges plus d'un
million et demi de personnes ont quitté
l'embouchure du mississippi qu que
l'ouragan devrait atteindre cette nuit
d'énormes embouteillages gérés par des
policiers des soldats de la garde
nationale résultant de ce départ massif
des habitants de la région la ville de
la nouvelle orléans qui est en dessous
du niveau de la mer espère bien résisté
de nombreuses digues devrait la protéger
à paris le défilé du siècle sur la plus
belle avenue du monde 2000 véhicules
pour marquer le centenaire du salon de
l'automobile de l'arc de triomphe aux
invalides des premières voitures
présentées il ya tout juste un siècle
jusqu'aux derniers prototypes des grands
constructeurs
reportage eric vassieux aux bruits verte
sur m'étais boutabout ces deux mille
voitures vous présentant un siècle
l'industrie automobile
je suivrai sur plus de dix kilomètres de
long en tête du défilé des panhard
renault de dion bouton toutes fabriquées
avant de 1899 à une époque où la france
comptait 620 constructeurs automobiles
et kara dante
elle avance à dix kilomètres heure en
descendant la plus célèbre avenue du
monde
un siècle de créativité autour de
l'automobile et ce sont toutes les modes
toutes les époques qui défilent devant
les yeux des spectateurs
pour les vingt mille personnes ayant
bravé la pluie pour admirer ces
magnifiques carrosserie c'est l'occasion
de se plonger dans un passé pas si
lointain
ce extraordinaire tout le monde a
retrouvé une voiture qui l'a conduit
tout qui l'a vu avec ses parents au tout
si vous aviez un choix à faire on a fait
une en particulier à quatre ce serait
laquelle on les cherche une aiguille
dans une botte de foin pointe
mais quand les voitures d'hier tombe en
panne comme aujourd'hui un seul
carburant
l'huile de coude
après le défilé de ses 700 véhicules de
collection c'était au tour des voitures
du futur de montrer le bout de leur
calandre automobile à énergies nouvelles
ou d'un temps révolu
c'est à chaque fois une façon différente
d'envisager la vie et de rêver sur hier
et demain
et en tête de ce défilé du siècle une
voiture française à la sentant à son
volant l'un des anciens dirigeants de la
marque par portrait l'ukba 6-1 et
frédérick basile cet homme à l'âge de sa
voiture 85 ans tous deux ont également
un autre point commun leur nom panhard
une marque française devenue une légende
c'était l'époque où pour démarrer il
fallait d'abord pomper pour faire
remonter les sens du réservoir vers le
carburateur jean panhard aux côtés de
son père est resté à la tête de
l'entreprise pendant près de 30 ans la
première voiture de la marque a vu le
jour avant lui c'était en 1891
c'est pourquoi mon père est au volant et
sur cette photo on voit le malheureux
mécaniciens qui est en train d'essayer
de faire partir la voiture est en
réalité on en a on a fait frôlé
l'incident parce que vous voyez la reine
qui est tout à côté de la voiture
si jamais la décence et d'être enflammés
sur une explosion on perdait la reine
d'angleterre ce qui aurait été 13 ans
nus mais l'histoire de l'entreprise
panhard a été bouleversé par un mauvais
diagnostic des médecins sur le seul
héritier de la marque
les médecins l'avaient condamné et il
avait raison puisque mon pauvre on est
mort mais quand il ya mort d'homme 87
ans
mais cette erreur de médecins étaient
tout à fait dommageable pour la firme
parce que mon oncle nous voyons que son
fils ne lui succédera semblant pas avant
d une grande partie de ses actions
85 ans plus tard ce carrosse des temps
modernes démarre comme au premier jour
l'occasion pour l'homme et sa machine de
vivre une nouvelle jeunesse président du
salon de l'automobile pendant vingt ans
jean panhard a rencontré grâce à la
voiture de beaux paysages mais aussi des
reines des rois et des présidents de la
république comme le général de gaulle
c'était vraiment un président
remarquable en ce sens qu'ils faisaient
exactement ce que je voulais quand on
lui dit d'aller à ce stade il y avait
quand à la hausse va continuer
voici la dernière panhard fabriqués au
début des années 60 avec déjà des lignes
très futuriste souligné par ses phares
arrondis mais en 65
la marque est racheté par citroën
aujourd'hui aucune voiture n'a survécu
au poids de la concurrence
seul un véhicule militaire est encore
fabriqué sous le nom panhard pourrait
peut-être imaginer qu'un jour je mets
mon ressort et quand on fabrique des
moteurs tracteurs pour moi un grand
plaisir
vas y ça s'arrangerait 15 ans cuillère
formule 1 avec la victoire du finlandais
mika hakkinen qui a remporté le grand
prix du luxembourg devant l'allemand
schumacher à qui ne reprend donc seul la
tête du championnat du monde devant son
rival allemand un grand prix de la fin
de la saison
laurent frédéric bollée la finlande
reprend l'avantagé
mika hakkinen triomphe au pays de
schumacher et prend une option sur le
titre
à la veille de son 30e anniversaire
c'est un beau cadeau à keenan qui ne
s'est pas affolé au départ
or vine devant schumacher en fait ça ne
voulait pas dire grand chose car dès
avant la fin du premier tour les choses
rentrent dans l'ordre chez ferrari
schumacher passe en tête
l'allemand tente alors de creuser
l'écart aussitôt derrière airlines va
jouer évidemment les fidèles lieutenants
akin n est retardé
il faut attendre le 14e tour pour que le
val-andré parviennent enfin à ses fins
il s'installe en deuxième position tout
va se jouer au 28e tour schumacher s'est
arrêté 50 au couteau c'est au tour
d'aquitaine qui a déjà refait sur la
piste une partie de son retard
d'observer son ravitaillement à la
sortie c'est juste ses limites c'est
chaud mais c'est fait akin n est bien
devant est alors une bataille entre
hommes au sommet les deux ténors sont
seuls au monde ils ne se lâchent pas et
puis dixième par dixième à kinnen
construit finalement sa victoire
schumacher chez lui car le grand prix du
luxembourg se déroule en allemagne
n'abdique pas bien sûr la ferrari est
poussé dans ses derniers retranchements
mais rien n'y fait c'est le stand
mclaren qui est en tête 7e victoire de
la saison pour aquitaine qui reprend 4
points d'avancé au championnat avant la
dernière épreuve se fera le 1er novembre
prochain pour le grand prix du japon
il faudra se lever très tôt pour savoir
qui sera le nouveau champion retour aux
élections allemandes si vous prenez ce
journal en cours voici les derniers
résultats le chancelier helmut kohl est
battu avec 34,8 % des voix
gerhard schröder et le parti social
démocrate est arrivé en tête avec 41%
virgule 2 des voix une élection qui a
mobilisé les électeurs plus de 79 % de
participation
je vous propose maintenant l'exemple aux
alentours du circuit de formule 1 au
nürburgring un exemple de civisme
reportage philippe rochot pierre
moscovitch en moto en vélo en auto ils
étaient venus de toute l'allemagne pour
ce grand prix du luxembourg
trois cent mille personnes au nürburging
cet après midi pour soutenir schumacher
qui dit on roule pour helmut kohl
mais ces fanas de la formule 1 n'avait
pas oublié leur devoir de citoyen même
ceux qui sont venus camper dès hier soir
pour apercevoir leurs idoles
votre pronostic c'est quoi hall a
construit sans doute remporté par
schumacher
mais pour les élections à les élections
c'est quoi qui va l'emporter
j'ai voté par correspondance sur les
billets on nous a conseillé de voter
comme ça sinon on n'aurait pas eu le
temps et pour qui avaient voté
je ne veux pas le diriger on est partis
à 5 heures du matin on va rentrer tard
on croit pas voter alors j'ai voté par
correspondance moi aussi ainsi les
billets de la course rappelait aussi aux
amateurs de formule 1 qu'il fallait
voter après leur déception d'avoir vu
schumacher battu les allemands
s'interrogeait ainsi sur l'avenir de
leur chancelier j'ai voté pour la télé
ou pour helmut kohl je pense que la
coalition actuelle va rester mais ce
sera très chaud ce soir c'était les
finlandais qui avait le sourire avec la
victoire d'aquitaine l'échec de
schumacher supporter d'helmut kohl était
il déjà un mauvais présage pour les
chrétiens démocrates
personne n'osait le dire ce soir mais
beaucoup le pensaient et nous retrouvons
maintenant à berlin en direct étienne
françois bonsoir vous êtes historien
spécialiste de l'allemagne
alors comment vous réagissez vous à la
chute d'helmut kohl est ce une surprise
au moins par l'ampleur des voix qui ont
choisi le changement
oui c'est du surprise à cause de
l'ampleur des transferts qui se sont
passés la chute très importante des
chrétiens-démocrates qui dépassent ce
qu'on attendait de la progression des
sociaux démocrates en sens inverse c'est
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
république fédérale que les sociaux
démocrates ont une telle avance contre
leurs rivaux conservateurs de ce point
de vue là on peut dire que le vote n'a
pas seulement été un vote négatif de
rejet du chancelier kohl mais qu'il a
été aussi un vote positif de choix d'une
nouvelle politique et de choix en même
temps d'une nouvelle majorité pour la
conduire on a quand même le sentiment
qu'au fond c'est la victoire d'un
professionnel qui a fait une très belle
campagne pas nécessairement sur son
programme parce que je roeder un peu dit
tout et son contraire
c'est davantage le succès de ce
professionnel qui a su utiliser les mets
ya derrière la victoire effectivement de
gerhard schröder il ya la victoire d'un
homme et d'une équipe
l'équipe menée par müntefering qui est
le responsable du parti social démocrate
et qui a organisé toute la campagne de
manière très professionnelle en veillant
à pouvoir parler à différents types
délectera et à garder toujours la porte
ouverte
en fonction du résultat des élections de
telle sorte qu'on puisse faire alliance
soit avec les verts soit avec les
chrétiens-démocrates c'est un une
réussite de professionnalité qui fait
contraste avec les nombreux cafouillages
qu'il y a eu du côté de la majorité
perdante
que vous inspirent les voix de l'extrême
droite
elle augmente on l'a dit l'extrême
droite a doublé en quelques années mais
elle ne sera pas représenté au parlement
double réaction face à cela
effectivement les suffrages ont augmenté
aussi bien au niveau fédéral qu'au
niveau local aux élections du
mecklembourg for porn
mais en même temps l'extrême droite n'a
pas passé la barre des 5% alors qu'elle
l'avait fait il ya quelques gars
quelques mois dans le land de saxe
anhalt est ce si je l'interprète comme
un sursaut des électeurs au moment de
mettre leur bulletin dans l'urne
et comme un signe de responsabilité donc
de maturité de la démocratie allemande
il ya trente ans que les communistes
seront encombrant pour les
sociaux-démocrates au pouvoir
bon on imagine qu'il n'a pas de grandes
chances pour qu'il est comme en france
une participation au gouvernement non de
ce point de vue là les choses sont nets
s'ils y à une coalition entre les
sociaux démocrates et les verts et c'est
ce qui paraît le plus probable
actuellement est ce qui est souhaité
d'ailleurs par la majorité des électeurs
cette coalition ne pourra se faire qu'à
la condition qu'elle ait la majorité
absolue des sièges au parlement mais il
y aura une opposition aux communistes
plus forte que ce n'était le cas
antérieurement plus résolue porté par
des suffrages plus nombreux et qui show
qui jouera le rôle d'un rappel à l'ordre
quelque sorte pour cette coalition au
cas où elles seraient tentés d'avoir une
dérive excessivement centriste ceci
étant ce n'est pas un danger là non plus
me semble-t-il pour la démocratie
allemande car ce parti successeurs des
communistes est non seulement un parti
qui ne participera pas à la coalition au
pouvoir
mais d'autre part c'est un parti qui
parce
là va se trouver encore plus intégrée
dans le jeu politique ouest allemand et
donc indirectement c'est un parti qui va
faire en sorte que l'intégration
politique de l'allemagne de l'est
s'accélère je crois que c'est ça
l'élément le plus important pour
l'avenir avec un point supplémentaire
important pour les allemands de l'est ce
parti n'est pas seulement un parti post
communiste il est aussi et peut être
avant tout un party de défense des
intérêts régionaux et il veillera à ce
que la candide la coalition qui arrivera
au pouvoir n'oublie pas les intérêts des
habitants de l'allemagne de l'est comme
ç'avait été un peu le quart
antérieurement
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et pour toutes ses analyses et
ses précisions retour en france réaction
à chaud à présent à l'ambassade
d'allemagne sur place leurs ambitions un
grand portrait d'helmut kohl seul sous
la pluie dans les jardins de
l'ambassadeur d'allemagne à paris comme
un symbole de défaite pour la cdo
pourtant ici ni cris de joie ni
tristesse afficher les invités de
l'ambassadeur s'attendait à ce résultat
et dès 18 heures les interrogations
étaient plus nombreuses que les
commentaires pour l'instant c'est à dire
étant donné que ce qui fait qu ils sont
quatre cd ou séjour il n'a pas appliqué
une politique socialement extrêmement
orientée goffi nouvelle étape c'est trop
dit ça s'écrit toujours dans la
continuité en même temps avec un
changement de gouvernement aussi il a un
changement il a
il y aura une nouvelle étape je pense
pas que c'est un un carrefour ou en
changent de direction
certainement pas soirée spéciale musique
et cocktail de toute façon l'ambiance
était à la détente et au consensus le
plus satisfait de ces résultats
semblaient être un français jean marie
bockel président du groupe france
allemagne à l'assemblée nationale et
député socialiste du haut-rhin des
choses je suis très heureux et le
renforcement du pôle social démocrate
après blair après jospin maintenance
fraude r c'est une bonne chose
ils ont la construction européenne parce
qu'à côté d'un euro fort on va pouvoir
construire l'europe sociale c'est-à-dire
intéresser nos concitoyens français
allemands à la construction européenne
ce soir dans les salons de la résidence
de l'ambassadeur le portrait le plus
entouré était celui de gerhard schröder
non geignant direct philippe rochot vous
êtes au siège de la cd ou à bonn
est-ce que déjà sur place on commença à
préparer l'après cool je viens de voir
le chancelier kohl là qui donnait une
interview à la 2e chaîne de télévision
allemande il a l'air détendu
résigné il accepte sa défaite mais ici
on parle beaucoup maintenant de la
succession qui va se présenter aux
prochaines élections dans quatre ans il
est confirmé que c'est wolfgang schauble
son dauphin l'homme qui est en fauteuil
roulant qui a subi un attentat en 1990
et qui a eu la moelle épinière
sectionnée
et bien c'est à cet homme-là qu'on va
confier finalement le destin de la télé
ou peut être le destin du pays
c'est en tout cas à snacks que préparent
les chrétiens démocrates actuellement
merci philippe peut nous rejoignons
maintenant olivier lerner en direct de
bonnes du spd que va faire le futur
chancelier ce qu'ils préparent déjà la
future cohabitation si cohabitation il
ya absolument béatrice se garent h
roller nous a quittés il ya un peu plus
d'une demi heure maintenant il s'est
retiré avec son état-major ses
principaux conseillers dont brigitte
sauzay l'ex interprète de françois
mitterrand qui maintenant va là le
conseiller sur les affaires franco
allemand de garches hauts de seine que
retirer dans ses appartements
ici à bonn alors il y aura la fête c'est
surtout le moule toute la famille
sociale démocrate et est évidemment le
foriic et très joyeux ce soir cela dit
grâce aux lèvres pense sans doute déjà
dès à présent à pâtir sunu
gouvernement alors il va sans doute
devoir le faire donc avec les verts les
verts demandent beaucoup à guéret à
chaleur et notamment vous le savez le
portefeuille de ministre des affaires
étrangères qui devrait revenir au
charismatique yoshka fischer mais les
verts et les rouges se déchirent depuis
des années notamment sur les questions
d'énergie sur le nucléaire sur le
charbon sur le prix de l'essence aussi
on peut penser que cette nuit ne sera
pas seulement une partie de plaisir pour
le nouveau chancelier médias nous la
suivrons parce que voilà ce que l'on
pouvait dire pour l'instant en tout cas
dans ce journal sur ces élections
allemandes mais rendez-vous à 22h45 pour
une page spéciale allemagne résultats et
premiers commentaires avant de terminer
ce journal championnat de france de
photos sous marines ce week-end à
banyuls-sur-mer dans les
pyrénées-orientales ces photographes
amateurs ont essayé de concilier l'art
avec looneo lamberton françoise mesures
d'étranges paparazzi photographiant de
non moins surprenant mannequin c'est
l'image la plus inattendue de ce
championnat de france de photos sous
marines
car le but de la compétition n'est pas
de faire un reportage animalier mais des
photographies d'art de transformer la
mer en un immense jardin ou d'onces les
sirènes et c'est agréable de jouer son
rôle et combien la mer est belle parce
que là encore c'est ça le message joue
un peu à la sirène sous l'eau auxerre
durant tout le week end à
banyuls-sur-mer dans les
pyrénées-orientales 22 photographes et
leurs mannequins sont partis à la soude
des trésors de la méditerranée tous sont
des amateurs éclairés qui pratiquent
leur passion depuis plusieurs années
c'est le cas du nouveau champion de
france
et comme les autres c'est d'abord
l'amour de la plongée qui l'a amené à la
photographie sous marine
car elle possède une magie particulière
ab c'est un petit peu c'est l'ambiance
les couleurs qu'on a pas se rendent au
dehors et puis la surprise toujours
puisqu'on n'a pas la couleur
quand on fera la photo on a toujours la
surprise de voir les résultats dans une
seconde surprise par exemple hier matin
on avait le ciel gris sans voix les
landes relier les imageries égard on a
vu les apôtres tout l'été bleus et c'est
vrai qu'il ya tout un monde entre ce que
l'on voit sous l'eau et leur ont dû
diapos c'est d'ailleurs sur les photos
que l'on découvre les couleurs
naturelles comme si l'anr réservé ce
cadeau uniquement à ceux qui viennent la
contempler
mais c'est se termine ce journal je vous
en rappelle les deux principaux titres
les élections en allemagne
le chancelier helmut kohl et battu 34 8%
des voix contre 41,2 à son adversaire
gerhard schröder le leader des sociaux
démocrates sera le prochain chancelier
de l'allemagne un tournant historique
c'est la fin de l'ère cool à toulon 2e
tour des législatives partielles de
casanova l'a candidats socialistes
devanceraient sandrine le chevalier le
taux de participation avoisiner les 50%
soit six points de plus que la semaine
dernière dans un instant la météo
présentée par nathalie rihouet 20h52
votre série urgences 22h45 donc une
spéciale allemagne résultats et premier
commentaire avec bruno roger petit 23h50
le musique au coeur ce soir et brut
gérer les trois journalistes parlent
librement de l'actualité musicale de
l'opéra bastille à bayreuth et
d'aix-en-provence à salzbourg
on y retrouvera entre autres samuel avec
écrit en factuellement dans don carlo l
opéra bastille demain à 20 heures de
retrouver claude sérillon je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sur contout
oh
tous